you
hi everyone is cheering I have another
cool chess puzzle to share with you this
one was composed by Frederic Lazar in
1935 probably my favorite composer I've
shared a few of his compositions over
the years in this playlist and they
never seem to disappoint it's white to
move and it's up to you to try and find
the best continuation I encourage you as
usual to spend some time with these
maybe set this position up on one of
your own boards and come back to the
video to see the solution okay here we
go first move is d7 if Bishop takes
Bishop a white promotes to a queen and
goes on to win but what do we do if the
bishop goes to h6 now if white promotes
to a queen
black will win with a discovered check
check me so well what's the idea the
idea here is to play 2f8 White must make
this move now Bishop takes Bishop white
promotes to a queen and goes on to win
if the bishop goes to g5 we go to e7
once more trying to deflect the bishop
offer this diagonal Bishop takes Bishop
in this case this will result in a draw
y promotes two Queen Bishop takes Queen
stalemate no legal moves for white
and there's one other square for the
black Bishop Bishop f4
the idea Bishop d6 follows so wherever
the bishop goes the white Bishop plays
to these squares and continually tries
to deflect the bishop off of this key
diagonal no don't go anywhere this is
not the solution this is only part of it
this is as far as I took this
composition I didn't take it any deeper
there is a deeper point to this you
ready
after Bishop takes bishop in this case
in white promotes to a queen what is
white doing after Bishop f4
there is not a good move for white black
is winning this position white will soon
have to give the queen up for the bishop
to stop mate so let's just say the Queen
goes to d2 right now or one move later
King f3 Queen is pinned and the queen is
lost black goes on to win this King and
pawn endgame so what's the trick here
how does black hold this black excuse me
how does white hold this how does white
make this a draw well
you promote to a rook
how is this trying exactly well
for starters let's say the bishop picks
up this pawn this is one move White has
this is one resource White House rook d3
with the idea to pick up the veep on and
then be there in time to hunt down this
guy and if King takes rook stalemate and
if the bishop does not take the pawn but
rather goes to f4 what is white doing
now well the only move here which holds
the draw rook d2 how is this different
from when the Queen was on detail well
if King f3 in this position stalemate
promoting to a queen turns out to be too
strong now
if the King doesn't go to F three let's
say Bishop g5 if there's some separation
between the King and Bishop on this
diagonal the rook puts pressure on the
bishop
pressure on the bishop
and if king of for when they're next to
each other and the king is ready to give
this check that's when you return to d2
Bishop h6 you put pressure on the bishop
King g5 they're next to each other rook
d2 once more setting up this stalemate
trick King moves to one of these two the
game is over draw
a very clever stalemate resource I'm not
saying that another composition doesn't
exist like this what I am saying is that
this is the first time I am experiencing
a composition like this I've seen ones
we're promoting to a queen result in a
draw but promoting to a rook results in
a win but this is the first time I'm
experiencing one we're promoting to a
queen is a loss but promoting to a rook
is a draw what about for you feel free
to share your any feedback you have in
the comment section below and yeah I
hope you enjoyed this one as much as me
that's all for now take care bye
you